hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Randy Bryce
the innocent bystander so today we're
gonna check out that trailer for Mortal
Kombat X Tanya's fatalities brutalities
X ray and intro so far I played this
game on Dan's Channel princess crucified
I like how like how Jax gets stabbed in
the chest it's ripped open and then he's
still like no no he hits his head
smashed in yeah
that's why how they save the black guy
for last to get killed [ __ ] racist
killed first I don't know I'm trying to
make this video more political I figure
you know if I'd like make it a racist
issue job done job done and then people
will think like wow Ryan's really
standing yeah respect just like every
horror movie you kill the black guy off
first that's terrible but it shows that
they're important cuz were you looking
at my hair
no I was looking at the gravity poster
oh don't ever make me self-conscious
like that again well why stop there
Brandi a new trailer just dropped a
couple hours ago
Tanya same character vs. scorpion let's
do this
[Music]
John's ass
oh wait not enough time this way my
daughter looks so complicated to learn
all this [ __ ] I know but it's so hard
[ __ ] him up yeah that scorpions my
favorite [ __ ] it's on the shins man on
the shins Day weekend oh I want to see a
fatality or some charity should play
this game Randy I think we should I
actually love this game I used to play
Mortal Kombat's a really fun game I had
Veronica play this game with us too oh
really
yeah I mean it wasn't a lets place but
she was able to she lost a lot she
bursts someone then she burst another
person and she lost it was really
embarrassing
no it's not okay she's my girlfriend
she's learning no I don't have time to
wait for my girlfriend to learn if she's
gonna be my girlfriend she has to be
perfect right away that's not fair I'll
tell you what's not fair a black guy
getting killed off last
bringing it full circle circle that's
what I just did here well anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the real rejects
hey if you're new to the channel know
what you can do you can subscribe check
out Brady's channel subscribe it's fun
because you know Brandis she's she's
Maggie she's goofy you know like people
were youtubers I'm you have personality
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter and normally I do
a product placement sex joke here but
instead we're gonna shout out mother
[ __ ] who deserves a shout-out DJ to
code what's up Ryan and Dutch fan here
Dutch that I don't know what they sound
like
I'm following your account for a long
time now and I love your videos I am a
DJ music producer and I try to get
noticed but you're getting notice now my
friend I always try to blend my passion
for music and movies and one thing yep
it's called movie scores well DJ to code
dude I'm proud that you are following
your passion for music and movies you
know I'm planning on producing film
specifically adult entertainment films
and a DJ to code I'm looking for someone
who can understand my passion for music
and movies as well so we can create a
great score for the double anal zine DP
you know Brandy's sorry knit two [ __ ]
one ass two [ __ ] one ass two [ __ ] one
ass
dj2 code start working on that music two
cups